il est samedi matin
je suis à Biarritz et je viens regarder
l'océan à la côte des basses
un café dans une main un croissant dans
l'autre
c'est là on découvrant l'instant et
l'horizontalité que j'ose affronter
cette question
et sans moi qu'est-ce qu'il restera de
cette journée
sans moi qu'est-ce qu'il sera de l'état
du monde comment est-ce qu'il tournera
quand sera-t-il des familles des
inondations des couchers de soleil des
câlins de l'océan des saisons
à ce moment précis un rayon du soleil
est venu caresser mon visage
comme pour me dire que je n'étais pas
insignifiante mais que j'avais mon rôle
à jouer
ce rayon de soleil m'a crié que je
n'étais pas un pion qui enchaînerait sa
vie comme un parfait petit soldat ni une
étiquette que l'on collerait sur un CV
encore moins une tête que l'on rangerait
dans une case
c'est un samedi matin je suis à la Côte
des Basques et avec ce rayon de soleil
sur ma joue on se fait une promesse
celle de faire quelque chose de cette
vie de ce passage
c'est un samedi matin j'ai 24 ans et je
décide de ne plus laisser ma vie être
dictée par d'autres
la question est maintenant la suivante
avec moi qu'est-ce que ça changera de
l'état du monde
je m'appelle Victoria et ça c'est les
autres qui l'ont décidé sans moi ça
aurait aussi pu être Adélaïde ou Perrine
si j'ai 24 ans aujourd'hui j'ai
longtemps attendu des autres
les autres pour me dire quoi faire quand
le faire comment le faire
les autres pour lancer le feu vert
pour m'assurer que j'avance sur la bonne
voie que c'est bien que c'est beau que
c'est ok
j'attendais des autres qu'il me rassure
qu'il me disent qui je suis et comment
on conduit une vie
j'attendais que l'on soit avec moi pour
faire
alors j'ai enfilé des blouses de chimie
trop grande en terminale S même si je
révorerais je rêvais de dévorer du Kant
en elle mais vous savez faire S c'est
bien ça ouvre toutes les portes alors
quand on est une élève sérieuse il faut
y aller alors j'y suis allé un peu
naïvement comme si le choix du non choix
dessiner une vie
voilà comment on en vient allez c'est
notre vie être dicté par des camps quoi
comment ça avec
est-ce qu'à vous aussi on vous a dit
quand tu auras un CDI tu seras
tranquille quand tu auras un enfant
alors tu seras grand sans cet ami tu
serais plus heureux avec plus d'argent
tu serais épanouie
vous avez peut-être ressenti ces
pressions là et si non je pense à vous
parce qu'elles m'ont longtemps envahi et
je travaille encore à m'en défaire
j'ai grandi jusqu'à aujourd'hui avec
cette idée que nos vies étaient
construites sous conditions
qu'il n'y avait alors que peu de place
pour la spontanéité la liberté les
détours et les rebonds
quelle tristesse quel manque
d'imagination
de quoi avons-nous peur en hyper
contrôlant nos vies par des il faudrait
que
parce qu'au final qui de mieux que
moi-même pour savoir quoi dire quoi
faire quoi penser
parce que sans moi il n'y a rien de
cette journée
sans moi il n'y a pas de café au réveil
il n'y a pas de découverte de
l'horizontalité un samedi matin à la
côte des basses
sans moi il n'y a pas de musique sous la
douche il n'y a pas de podcast tous les
lundis matins il n'y a pas de potager à
la maison
sans moi il reste le monde les autres et
ce même bateau que notre terre
sans moi il reste la menace de la vie et
la destruction de ce même bateau
et avec moi je crains que ça ne change
pas grand chose à cette vertigineuse
menace
on est 8 milliards d'êtres humains sur
Terre ce n'est pas moi qui vais faire
une grande différence ni toi non plus
d'ailleurs Richard en fait tout ça ne
sert à rien
ma vie sans plastique et sans voiture
mes vêtements de seconde main ma croix
tiré sur l'avion
tout ça ne fera finalement pas le poids
face à un total énergie qui construit le
plus gros oléoduc chauffer au monde en
Ouganda et en Tanzanie
ni face à un Bertrand qui prend l'avion
tous les matins et qui claque son argent
dans des villas aux quatre coins du
monde
je me laisse miner par les rapports du
GIEC par les lectures de Jean-Marc
Jancovici timothéparrick Pablo servigne
j'écoute parler et vassadouness
et je dors climat je me sens si petite
face à temps pourquoi m'infliger ça
affronter les repas de famille avec mon
végétarisme de voir affirmer mes
convictions et voir que rien ne bouge
rien ne bouge
alors pourquoi pas faire comme tout le
monde suivre la voie que tout le monde
suit ça serait tellement plus simple
ça m'éviterait bien des débats des
insomnies des explications de
l'inconfort
et puis il y a des jours où je me
rappelle pourquoi je fais les choses je
pense à la fameuse part du Colibri et à
la sobriété heureuse de Pierre rapie et
je comprends qu'il n'y a personne à
convaincre que moi pour ressentir
ressentir tant la sobriété et la
lignement me rendent profondément plus
heureuse
alors ces jours-là je me dis qu'aussi
minime soit-il je ferai tout mon
possible pour que l'impact de mon
passage sur terre puisse compter
étrangement j'ai changé ma vie en
voulant la sauver
agir pour le climat n'est plus devenu
une contrainte mais une façon de
repenser tout mon quotidien sous le
spectre de la sobriété
et j'y ai pris goût tellement goût que
ça m'a révélé
j'ai arrêté de manger tout et n'importe
quoi par compulsion et j'ai commencé à
mettre les mains dans la terre pour
cultiver mon propre potager et vous
savez quoi je n'ai jamais ressenti un
état de joie aussi pur que le jour où ma
première carotte est sortie de terre
il en faut donc vraiment peu pour être
heureux
comment sommes-nous venu à préférer le
béton à la terre
j'ai remplacé mes vêtements par des
livres dans mon dressing pour ne garder
que l'essentiel et de cet essentiel je
n'achète plus rien neuf sauf pour de
rares occasions
alors au-delà des actions directes et
quotidiennes en faveur d'un mode de vie
plus responsable j'évite compris qu'agir
me faisait avant tout du bien
c'est comme si j'épluchait petit à petit
ma vie de tout superflu pour ne garder
que ce qui comptait vraiment
j'ai laissé de la place pour le temps
long pour la contemplation la méditation
les relations saines l'écriture la
lecture tout décanter tout trouver sa
place
remettre de la conscience dans mon
quotidien m'a poussé à porter plus haut
ce rapport au monde
alors j'ai créé mon podcast nouvelle
oeil avec lequel je tends chaque semaine
mon micro jaune a une personne qui elle
aussi a décidé que ça ne serait pas sans
mais avec elle
alors pour ça aussi on m'a dit attends
Victoria tu es encore jeune termine tes
études et ton podcast tu le lanceras
après
il n'y avait que moi pour décider d'oser
tendre mon micro jaune
pour ne pas attendre ce plus tard mais
pour faire confiance à ce c'est
maintenant
il n'y avait que moi pour oser me
détacher de ma rationalité de mon mental
et pour faire confiance à mon intuition
et ce podcast a changé ma vision du
monde
chacun de mes invités à sa façon ma
conforté dans cette idée qu'il faut
oser
Marc de la meynardière qui a quitté la
finance pour créer son écolieu la
cambrousse Anaïs Vanel qui a quitté
Paris pour l'écriture et le surf dans
les Landes
à ce jour ce sont 128 personnes à qui
j'ai tendu mon micro jeune
128 personnes qui à leur façon impactent
le monde
en créant ce podcast j'ai utilisé mon
présent pour construire mon futur je
n'ai pas attendu que l'on me donne le
feu vert mais je l'ai fait passer au
vert
alors j'ai publié mon premier livre
sorti des études ce qu'on n'apprend pas
à l'école
puis j'ai commencé à prôner la sobriété
lors d'événements et des conférences
partout en France qui font aujourd'hui
mon quotidien
très vite j'ai compris que le CDI et les
cases ne seraient pas dans mon camp du
moins pas pour l'instant
mais que la liberté et la multiplication
de projets autour de la quête de sens
donnerait un sens à ma vie
alors oui pensez ainsi sa vie demande
une certaine résistance face aux
conventions
mes pensées ma vie sous le spectre de
l'écologie a changé mon monde intérieur
alors là vous vous dites qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait mince elle a un trou elle a
oublié son texte la pauvre mince depuis
le temps qu'elle le prépare là c'est
votre mental qui a repris le dessus
j'ai si longtemps laissé mon mental
prendre le dessus
je travaille tous les jours petit à
petit à m'en détacher en essayant
d'appliquer ce fameux développement
personnel que l'on nous vend à toutes
les sauces
mais je préfère parler d'écologie
intérieure
loin du tri des déchets j'ai compris que
l'écologie intérieure était intimement
rattachés à cette lutte mondiale qui est
la crise climatique il n'y aura pas de
protection du climat sans protection de
soi nous sommes la nature
si l'on ne prend pas soin de soi comment
prendre soin des autres et du monde
et apprendre à se connaître ça ne peut
se faire qu'avec soi-même
c'est quand j'ai arrêté de culpabiliser
de forcer de tenter de convaincre que
j'ai vu les changements autour de mon
entourage parce que c'est moi qui avait
changé
en étant plus heureuse et épanouie j'ai
montré l'exemple d'un monde plus apaisé
moins dépendant des besoins futiles et
extérieurs
en incarnant le changement au quotidien
sans le savoir j'ai tendu la main à
celles et ceux que je culpabilisais
avant
alors papa a commencé à goûter mes plats
végétariens et à les aimer même mes amis
ont commencé à tester les vêtements de
seconde main et à aimer ça
faire le choix d'incarner au quotidien
une nouvelle utopie ça ne dépend
finalement que de moi
alors oui vous avez un impact aussi
minime que cela puisse vous sembler il
compte
je terminerai par cette phrase de
Margaret Med
ne doutez jamais qu'un petit groupe de
citoyens réfléchi et engagé
puisse changer le monde
on y va ensemble
[Applaudissements]